the region in the first quadrant first
quadrant bounded by the curve y equals
4x squared minus X to the fourth so this
is reader looking quartic that we've got
here that region which I've shaded in
yellow is add the x-axis sorry is
rotated about the y-axis there we go
find the volume of the solid of
revolution generate now let me just
point out quickly some people asking me
oh I can't do these early questions by
like just doing it the tuna way because
you can I'd like you're not too i'd like
you to sort of demonstrate like yes I do
know how slices work I know where they
come from but I will point out that even
if you did it by a two dimension that is
volumes by slices you just we're just
not describing the language okay so this
is what we've got and I'm just going to
put out there I don't expect you to make
a diagram you know this this colorful of
this you know etc as you can see even i
changed a little bit that's I could have
drafted but you know this looks better
however however you absolutely need to
work towards this when I've marked
students who've gotten a volume wrong I
can in a good three quarters of cases
trace it back to their diagram being
unclear and therefore unhelpful when
they try to work out these things which
of course gives you the integrand there
be able can generally integrate okay and
the kinds of functions you get are often
polynomials it's not let you get
something which just doesn't work you
just get something that's wrong okay so
I have rotated around the y-axis here so
my first line is going to need to look
something like this v equals because I'm
going around the x-axis ok yeah round
the x-axis you can see my slices are
perpendicular to the axis of rotation so
that again and get again that's what
makes slices slices so my height for
each bit is delta y is that ok so let's
begin by saying limit as Delta Y
approaches 0 I'm adding up a whole bunch
of phase because I'm going up along the
y-axis I'm going to have a
i equals something where do i go from
bottom to top you can actually just read
them off right 024 very good which of
course you'd actually have to go ahead
and work out but you can see it now and
then i'm just going to write my you can
see I've got to get an annulus every
time I slice across right so here is my
annulus volume okay great but then you
encounter this little little difficulty
in that I are at our huh there's a
couple of problems the first thing is
this is our our should be a function of
Y right I don't have a function of Y i
have y is a function of X that's my
first to lever the second owner it is
i'm usually used to getting this part
from like a constant or some function
and this part from a different function
you remember felt the one we started
with this money we had edx we had one on
X you later okay well I get one bit here
one bit there but both radii here the
inner and the other come from the same
function so how do i get two radii out
of the safe how do i distinguish between
these this radius and this radius okay
now those two problems are both solved
with the same step what i need is a
function of why I did this function as a
function of one okay so in other words i
need an x equals out of this right or
more usefully 18 x squared right which
is going to be important for us for a
second so we have nearly let's just
write down this function i'm going to
put this to one side and I've just got
to before i get to actually integrating
i need to work with this function at
work out what on earth is going on i
want x squared as the subject or x is
the subject would be nice but i noticed
it's according so i can get it squared
i'll be happy now it's not present it's
something very nice for for us I'm going
to do one thing which doesn't look like
it's dramatic change
but this is what i'm going to do now you
look at that you're like okay pull on
all of the knowledge of polynomial
functions and quadratics of a country
that you've won in the past i want x
squared to be the subject so what am I
going to do with that would you like it
on the clue
it's not much of a clue but i think it's
the last clue that i can give before i
give you the answer if i gave you a
question like this let's give you some
opera numbers okay and I said can you
solve this for me in solid have you know
exactly how to sonic solving of course
means lady X the subject that's what it
means solve the equation what would you
do for this thing you'd go for the
quadratic form because you're like I
can't think of 7th prime get lost okay
so you go straight there you might even
get some complex roots but that's fine
this is exactly like lips except that
it's not a quadratic in X it's a
quadratic in x squared which happens to
be exactly what I want right so let's
have a go in this X sweaty goes
quadratic formula how does it start it
will be minus B which is 4 plus or minus
B squared by this for a 1c yes ok now
it's not a constant but it is the
coefficient of the term which has no x
squared terms in it right so we're used
to thinking of x squared plus BX plus C
where C is constant but it doesn't have
to be constant what it really is it's
the term window x squared on it just
like this is the term with their answers
on it or or this is the term with no use
on right it's just whatever very very
custody / / 28 which is two ok like a
bucking monster
this looks like I could take a factor of
the square root of four out which means
i'm going to end up with this yeah / 2
and then i simplify huh
excuse me is this what you expected is
this what you expected well we expected
let's just dig it this a little bit more
and you don't need this line because we
actually want x squared but just out of
interest let's just write this because
this is true what does this indicate
well X is our function of wine and has a
plus or minus on the front what does
that mean it means horizontally I have a
pair of things which is exactly right an
even function after all right looks like
look there's a is left hand side that's
the negative x and there's a right hand
side that's the positive x so far so
good and then what's going on in DM
about x equals 2 and X equal to root 2
and x equals negative root 2 about those
two lines you again get two branches
right there's a negative part which goes
to the left and there's a positive
package goes to that right you have to
watch out there's actually two dot
positive to negative Jack Pinto okay in
other words you have four branches four
branches you've got this one and this
one which are both on the positive x I
and you've got this one and this one
which are both on the negative okay so
which ones do I want let's come back to
this which one is which 4x squared
equals this right excuse me one of them
is the inner radius I'm going to call
that are square and one of them is the
outer radius which one is weak
okay yes let's just pause for attacking
because this is confusing what's going
on right I know that there's a negative
case and there's a positive coast but
only in to work out which ones which now
thankfully for us the reason we called
the big R little R is because one is one
has to be for every value that I've
chosen except that one bigger has to be
gun the little up do you agree so exempt
so therefore the easiest way to
determine for which one is which is to
say look to take away a number and
that's positive i do because the square
root it's all real yeah to take away the
but must be smaller then 2 plus the same
number do you agree has to be right so
therefore that's how I know this is the
outrage simple simple way of doing don't
don't go rocket science just work out
which one's the big one and which ones
are smaller I've left them in a square
and a squared form because that's all I
need I don't actually need to know what
r is by itself even though I've written
that here we got square those things if
we find that out so I've already squared
them so now I'm actually ready to solve
okay let's do this I have accounted for
the fact that there's slices happening
so now I'm gonna turn this into an
integral from naught to four what am I
getting in here pi times what what's
capital a sweat that guy right
take away little R squared which is this
guy and I've accounted for the limit so
now I write dy instead of melt away okay
some sweet canceling happening in here
right I'm going to take a pie out so
that leaves me with that and then what
do you get here the twos cancel which
leaves you to root for motifs y dy okay
and after the integration topic we just
did we can make mincemeat of this right
I'm going to pull that to play at the
front this is 4 minus y to the half
formats one part so the first thing I'm
going to do is slap a minus sign for the
inside derivative that half is going to
become a three-on-two which means I'm
going to have 2/3 or two excuse me two
thirds yes and then I write it with the
increased power from not 24 yeah now let
me just double check that do i
differentiate this and get this bad a 3m
to the two of you cancel thumbs up the
by this side from you here cancels
thumbs up I've got my square root 4
minus y just like I wanted okay let me
tidy this up just to take it before I
valuate i'm going to take that-
two-thirds as a constant not there which
leaves me with this now this point I
raised a little bit of an eyebrow
because I'm like volumes better be
positive right but I've got a negative
sign out there what's with that why is
there a Nissan yeah that data side will
kids are it must be cuz look when we
evaluate these boundaries let's put this
guy on the way out the front here the
first evaluation gives you four motors
for which is zero and in the second one
gives you four motors 0 4 to the power
of three or two for the power 3 on 2
that's the square root of 4 is 2 and
then you raise it to the third power
eight so just like we were hoping those
double negatives cancel out and you get
em boy look sorry sir editing and I was
just running gay no okay yeah thank you
your way um so what was hard about this
question well getting a whiteboard
eraser the wax just part of the hard
part question what was hard about this
question what can you tell me what do
you think was tricky about yeah it looks
awesome look at that diagram it must be
a hard question I finally the radii of
my annulus the inner the other ones that
was not trivial that was some serious
work and even after you like you knew
all I have to do something with this I
don't think it was obvious so not only
of course okay now you see this and you
have to put this trick a lot because of
course we usually get our functions in
terms of it as functions of X right and
if you're rotating this way you need it
as a function of Y so you're going to
have to do this change in the future and
as you can see it's not impossible okay